Today we are finally taking a look at
the RX 960 XT 16 Gigabyte. Now this is
the Gigabyte Gaming OC and I think the
most innovative feature of this graphics
card is a cover that slides open to
reveal just plain RGB or you can cover
it to light up or illuminate the
Gigabyte RGB logo. That's right. That's
probably the most exciting thing about
this graphics card because unfortunately
the value just isn't really there. And
this is going to be my biggest complaint
about the RX960 XT6 GB just like it was
with the RTX 5060Ti 16 GB. And that is
the 60class cards. And before we move
into the gaming benchmarks, we're
actually going to pull up the value
charts because I feel like this is the
most important thing if you're looking
for a 60class card, whether it's from
AMD or from Nvidia. These 60class cards
have traditionally always been about
value. They've been the hardest hitting
value cards out of the stack, especially
in the case of Nvidia and their RTX 5060
Ti. The Ti that was always better value
than the 70S card and it always packed
just that raw price performance. Now,
when we look at the RX960 XT 16 GB, when
we compare it to either the street price
or the MSRP prices provided from AMD, in
either cases, when we stack that up
against the benchmark numbers that we'll
talk about very soon, it's worse value
than the RX970 16 GB. Now, granted, the
RX970 is an impressive card. I was
pretty impressed with that card. It's
still sad to see that this 60class card
has been hollowed out essentially to the
point where it feels like it's more a
50class card or an entrylevel gaming
graphics card just with 16 GB slapped on
top of it. Let's go through those gaming
benchmark numbers and then sum up with
what I feel is more or less a perfect
analogy to describe why I'm a bit upset
with this launch this time around right
after today's video sponsor. Do you need
to get Windows 10 or Windows 11
activated and don't want to spend $200
or some other exorbitant price? Well, if
so, today's video sponsor VIP SCD keys
has you covered. For as little as $15
using the coupon code BFTYC, you can get
Windows 10 activated. For a little bit
more, you can get Windows 11 activated,
too. Links in description below to find
out more. Now, let's go through these
gaming benchmarks. Starting off with the
first game and the only victory for the
960 XT 16 GB. This is starting off with
Final Fantasy 16. And here's where at
1440p we score a victory. 57 average FPS
versus 56. But stepping up to 4K, this
is where the 5060 Ti then does a little
bit better. So, they must have that
GDDR7 working a bit better on the 128
bit boss, which is something of a
disappointment on both these 60class
cards this time around. We'll talk about
that a little bit later. But let's go
through Rift Breaker here at 1440p. The
5060 Ti does score a bit better. And
then at 4K, it's also a similar story.
But one thing to talk about with the
60Ti, 16 GB from Nvidia is it is priced
significantly higher both on the street
and on its MSRP. So, we will have a
dedicated video on that tomorrow. But, I
thought I'd do a more traditional review
with these gaming benchmarks and just
show you all the numbers of all the
cards around the field. Even the 7800
XT, which ironically can be still had
for a really good price in Australia,
just not in the USA. though. Moving
through Marvel rivals, here's where the
960 XT 16 GB does do pretty well, but
it's still a chunk behind that of the
5060 Ti as well as the 7800 XT. Though,
moving through base marine 2. And here
is where at 1440p and both 4K, the 960
XT 16 GB does get beaten by the 5060 Ti
16 GB. Then going on to Fortnite, it's
not such of a big difference. And then
onto Blackmith Wukong at both 4K and
1440p high settings. 100% screen res. It
does start to fall behind a little bit
here too. Then when it comes to
Cyberpunk, the 960 XT is very close to
that of the 5060Ti.
Though when we look at the ray tracing
numbers, which we'll quickly pull up
some benchmarks here, both with FSR and
DLSS enabled versus not enabled. Here is
where if you're just going for raw rate
tracing on ultra settings, both the 5060
Ti and the 9060 XT class cards are not
really going to do this. But if when we
step it down to a base resolution at
1440p and upscale it to 4K, some of
these games can perform pretty well.
It's just for me personally, I do have
to take a side note as someone who
reviews the cards. I'm going to show you
the numbers, but I always like to add a
personal spin into my reviews. I've just
noticed with ray tracing the the tax the
like the FPS that you get taxed for the
visual fidelity that you're getting
given with ray tracing just isn't worth
it. I just find myself more and more not
turning on these ray tracing settings in
the games that I play. Whether it's a
new game or an older title, I just find
myself only really enabling certain
upscalers. And that also depends on the
game, whether it's DLSS or if it's FSR
or if it's the TSR built into the game
engine itself. So, the ray tracing, I
just thought I'd take a little sort of
detour off with ray tracing and whether
or not for me personally as as someone
who plays a lot of games, I don't really
find myself using ray tracing all that
much. Though, I'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments section about
ray tracing. Is it something that you
really focus on? But I think with the
DLSS upscaling, Nvidia definitely has
that advantage with their K update model
where that looks absolutely gorgeous and
you can get actually quite a bit of
performance. Ultimately, when it does
come to DLSS and RA tracing, Nvidia does
hold that advantage. It's just that I
place actually as time goes on, I'm
placing less and less weight on that
actual metric when I'm looking at pure
value. However, that said, let's look at
some power consumption numbers here. And
here's where the 960 XT16 GB, I've
actually got two models here, and
tomorrow we'll be taking a look at the
Steel Legend. We are using the Gigabyte
OC for these benchmarks here, but
ironically, these cards have the exact
same 182 watt power limit, which also I
measured from the wall. They were
clocking in pretty much the exact same
FPS and the exact same wattage numbers.
So, the power consumption itself was
actually quite poor for the performance
we were getting out of this card,
especially versus the 9070, which is
something we're going to talk about
after we look at the card and these
power consumption results here. Though,
if you want to undervolt this card,
here's where it does do quite well.
Dropping the power limit down 30%,
raising the memory to 2,800 megahertz,
and then putting on the fast timings, as
well as about a 60 m volt undervolt. The
Azeroth Steel Legend did go to around
minus70. So it did do a little bit
better in terms of being stable in Space
Marine 2, but then the Gigabyte maxed
out at around minus60. And the
performance numbers were pretty much
identical at these settings. But
ultimately, undervolting will give you a
boost in performance. Or if you want to
overclock, you can go down that route,
too. Use up a little bit more power as
well as get about a 10% boost out of
this card. So ultimately the stock
configuration I do recommend with the
960 XT either overclocking or
undervolting to get basically either the
same FPS but way less power consumption
or get a performance boost and use a bit
more power which even with the overclock
is not going to skew your power
efficiency level. So you're just going
to be getting extra performance and
using extra power in more or less a
linear fashion. Now before we get on to
a conclusion let's take a quick look at
this gaming OC from Gigabyte here. in
the model itself. Two slot design, three
smaller fans as well as a blowthrough
design at the back. And you've got there
at the back two display port twos as
well as an HDMI 2.1 out. Now, there's
some RGB on the side which has this
weird cover that you can either cover up
and illuminate the Gigabyte logo or you
can then push the Gigabyte logo aside
and just have some RGB there. Though,
out of the box, it does a really good
job with the thermals and it's pretty
whisper quiet. I'll let you guys take a
listen.
This is me whispering.
Just whispering near the phone.
It's quiet. And one thing I will note,
however, the ambient temperatures where
I am at the moment are quite cool.
Cooler than I'm used to doing the
testing on. And so I will point out
those memory junction temperatures. It
seems like it's a for me personally, it
has been quite high on all the RX 9000
series cards I've seen come through
here. So it looks like there is higher
VRAM temperatures in general. And with
that, I would personally recommend
undervolting the card and raising the
fan speeds, say in this case, to around
40%, but your VRAM temperatures when you
undervolt, there's less power draw, and
so your VRAM ultimately is going to
remain a lot cooler, but the whole
cooler is doing the GPU core and the
VRAM 2. Anyhow, with all the numbers
done, all the chat done about the GPU
itself, it's time to look at the actual
value proposition here with the 960 XT16
GB. And here's where I'm going to say I
just wanted a bit more from this lineup
of card. Not just from AMD, but also
from Nvidia. I thought, especially the
60Ti class card, I thought that should
have been a 192bit bus. And then in this
case, I thought the 960 XT should have
been a 192bit bus, too, where perhaps
they could have used 12 GB of VRAM and
just beefed up the actual raw
performance of the GPU core at the cost
of giving us a little bit less VRAM. as
I think the 8 GB is too little, but I
think the 16 GB in this format may be a
bit too much considering when you get to
that VRAM intensive situation where you
need 16 GB,
is your FPS going to really be okay? I
mean, you're going to be using up a lot
of GPU core power, too, in the process.
And so you're probably going to find
this scenario where you're just lowering
settings anyway, remaining under 12 GB
of VRAM for that particular game and
then wanting to get more FPS. And so
that's my whole crux with this situation
right here is just the value. We go back
to the value chart and the value isn't
as good as it is with AMD's own 70 card
this time around. And if we go down
memory lane from AMD, the RX6600 XT
versus say the RX6700 XT, there was a
value gap there that was in favor of the
RX6600 XT. And if we go back to say
Nvidia with the especially the RTX 3060
and 60Ti class cards versus the 3070,
they offered better value than the 70L
class card. But it seems like this time
around we've had this hollowing out of
this 60class segment. And it just shows
whether we're looking at the street
pricing or whether we're looking at the
actual MSRPs provided from AMD
themselves. And so for me personally as
an enthusiast over the last over 20
years being in u 25 years at least
actually being in a nerd playing games
on PC. I've just noticed that it's kind
of the easiest way to explain this to
you guys would be like going to buy ice
cream from the store and then you're
getting like ice confectionary now
instead of it being actual ice cream.
And this was actually a big thing in
Australia where the companies started
putting less like actual milk and stuff
in the ice cream and you went to the
store and you found yourself like why
does this taste different? Why is it
like not going off as quick? Right? And
so, and then why do I feel worse after
eating this so-called ice cream? And so,
there was laws passed in Australia where
if you wanted to get if a company wanted
to sell ice cream, they actually had to
put a certain amount of ingredients that
was reminiscent of what they used to put
in actual ice cream. And so, that's kind
of like how I feel when it comes to
buying a 60class card. Now, you've been
used to getting a certain level of
performance even relative versus the
higherend cards in the stack, but now
you're getting less. It's like going to
the store and yeah, you're like looking
for that ice cream, even the budget ice
cream, and instead you get nice
confectionary. And that's like that's
the easiest way for me to sum it up. I
don't feel like if I go out and buy a
9060 XT or a 9060 or if I'm going out to
Nvidia and buying a 5060 or 5060 Ti, I
feel like I'm just getting not what I'm
used to getting from a 60class card. And
so it really feels like both from Nvidia
and AMD, you're truly getting now this
50 car class card that when we look at
the power consumption, it's just been
ramped up to the max. And if we look at
those clock speeds, you'll notice that
they're very aggressive. In fact, this
uh card as well as the Steel Legend,
they went up for 3.4 GHz if I tune them
a little bit, which was insanely high.
So, they do go high in terms of clock
speed, but you're really maxing out what
you can do on a 128 bit bus. But if we
look at the raw numbers in the gaming
numbers, it's still just so far behind
the 9070 and the 9070 XT. They're
different just whole tiers of cards
completely to the point where the 970 XT
is nearly double the performance of the
960 XT. So that's kind of like my most
disappointing aspect with this card. But
now it's time to talk about a
recommendation and that is it is beating
out the value of the 5060 Ti. That's you
can see that in the charts and even
though it's giving a little bit less
performance, it does cost a significant
chunk less especially at retail. So AMD
have done a good job of beating Nvidia.
It's just that they've kind of followed
the same footsteps as Nvidia with this
60class card. That's just how I feel
about it. But ultimately, if you're
looking for the best value, I would
either look at getting a 9070 if you can
try and stretch it and get up. I know
it's a actually quite a significant
amount more money. Going up to a 9070 is
just going to get you a much better
experience on PC. But if you're looking
for it, I guess to play at 1080p, which
will come in tomorrow's video, we'll be
comparing directly the 5060 Ti versus
the 9060 XT at 1080p. If you're looking
for that just raw comparison with those
numbers and the 1080p numbers, we'll be
showing that direct comparison on which
should you buy. If you only have this
amount of money, you want to buy a new
GPU, should you get the 560Ti or the 960
XT, that comparison will be out
tomorrow. Though, at this stage, my
recommendation is with the 960 XT, I'd
try and get it a bit cheaper. I'd try
and get it around that $350 price point.
I'd like to see it even then a little
bit cheaper. I think it should be coming
out ultimately with better value, not
just with MSRP, but also street prices
versus the 9070. Come on AMD, you got to
make that happen for people. Lower the
prices or try and get the prices down a
bit because in Australia the prices are
actually pretty decent for the 9060 XT
16 GB. I have seen them coming in a
significant chunk cheaper than the 9070
as well as the RTX 5060Ti 16 GB. So,
summing things up for you guys with the
960 XT 16 GB, the traditional review
here, I think there's some better value
options out there at the moment, both
new and especially used. I would like to
see it come down a little bit in price,
but if you have to buy it, it's not a
bad card. It's just not great either.
So, that's kind of my like really just
eh with this card. That's my that's my
feelings. Anyhow, guys, hope you enjoyed
today's video. If you did, be sure to
hit that like button and we'll catch you
on another tech video very soon. Peace
out for now. Bye.
[Music]